all right well welcome to this special
edition of hannity i'm jason chaffetz in
tonight for sean
breaking tonight president trump
followed through on his threat to veto
the 740 billion dollar national defense
authorization act
known as the ndaa citing glaring
omissions by congress to address
abuse and big tech and scolding the
legislature for crafting a bill that
contradicts
the trump administration's america first
foreign policy
we'll have exclusive reaction with
national security advisor
ambassador robert o'brien just ahead but
first
president trump tonight is showing great
reluctance to sign congress's
massive omnibus spending package and
pandemic aid bill
demanding that congress provide direct
aid of two thousand dollars
who have suffered under no fault of
their own
and insisting that unnecessary and
wasteful spending be stripped
from the ongoing appropriations bill
that's larded up with pork
and frankly it's an appropriations bill
that nobody would have voted for
if they had to vote for it by itself now
remember
this is pret the president keeping his
word because back in 2018
he said he would never sign another bill
like this again
saying quote it's not right and it's
very bad for our country
take a look there are a lot of things
that
we shouldn't have had in this bill but
we were
in a sense forced if we want to build
our military we were forced to have
there are some things that we should
have in the bill
but i say to congress i will never sign
another bill like this again
i'm not going to do it again
nobody read it it's only hours old
some people don't even know what is it
1.3 trillion dollars it's the second
largest ever
president trump was elected to be a
disruptive force
he was never a so-called go along to get
along politician
time and time again president trump has
made it clear
that he hears the calls from the
american people to stand up to the
political class
and he hears calls to buck the status
quo and stand up to special interests
his only priority has been that of the
american people
and get this the president's call is
even being welcomed by
his most unhinged critics like speaker
nancy pelosi and congresswoman
ocasio-cortez
who say they're ready to boost the
amount of direct payments
something the president insisted on this
past summer
but here's the core question will they
also agree to cut out the pork
and all the reckless spending in the
legislation
because they probably won't
unfortunately
wasteful spending and misplaced
priorities are nothing new inside the
democrats ever-growing far-left
wish list for example republican senator
rand paul today
released his annual festivus airing of
the grievances
documenting case after case of waste
fraud and abuse
inside the swamp tweeting quote congress
gave you
six hundred dollars would you like to
know what they gave everyone else
15 million dollars to buy high-speed
boats for sri lanka
130 million dollars to promote democracy
in nepal
15 million to promote it in pakistan
and 33 billion to promote democracy in
venezuela
that seems to be going so well so far
now to be clear new funding by the end
of the year is imperative to prevent
a government shutdown but congress has a
choice to make
will they deliver needed aid to
americans struggling through the
pandemic
or will they retreat to the old ways of
washington where
pork pact projects foreign nations and
special interests
take priority over the forgotten men and
women of the united states of america